[Música]
el presidente ruso vladimir putin dijo
que está de acuerdo con que naciones
unidos y la cruz roja intervengan para
evacuar a civiles de la ciudad ucraniana
de mariupol esto tras su reunión en
moscú con el secretario general de la
onu entretanto en alemania más de 40
países se reunieron para coordinar la
entrega de armas a las autoridades de
kiev
la región pero rusa de transnistria en
moldavia ha sido escenario de una serie
de ataques terroristas en menos de 24
horas lo que ha elevado la atención
según la presidenta del país los hechos
son responsabilidad de las fuerzas
internas que buscan desestabilizar la
zona
el gobierno de méxico declaró finalizada
la etapa de pandemia del coi 19 para
desde ahora tratar el virus como
endémico así lo informó el secretario de
salud hugo lópez gatell que también
detalló que a partir del jueves podrán
ser vacunados todos los niños mayores de
12 años tenemos información desde la
capital mexicana
en france 24 estamos de vuelta con las
noticias que marcan las jornadas hoy
valentina torres sánchez y es un gusto
acompañarlos damos inicio en ucrania la
ofensiva rusa continua centrada en el
este el centro y el sur del territorio
ucraniano los bombardeos se produjeron
en las ciudades de sap orilla o dehesa y
mykolaiv a su vez en la ciudad de gerzón
las fuerzas rusas destituyeron al
alcalde e impusieron a un nuevo gobierno
local y anunciaron que buscarán
organizar un referendo para determinar
si el territorio quiere independizarse
de ucrania
entretanto el secretario general de
naciones unidas antonio guterres se
reunió en moscú con el presidente
vladimir putin quien indicó que en
principio estaba de acuerdo con que la
oro y la cruz roja intervengan en la
evacuación de civiles de la ciudad de
mariupol por su parte gutiérrez pidió
investigar de forma independiente si se
han cometido crímenes de guerra y no
dudó en calificar la ofensiva rusa de
invasión
en la guerra de ucrania la muerte de los
soldados es objeto de controversias
según moscú unos 1.350 militares han
fallecido desde el inicio de las
confrontaciones mientras que ucrania
sostiene que las cifras más altas
descubrir la verdad sin embargo no es
tarea fácil e implica costosos análisis
irene sabio y leticia álvarez enviadas
especial de france 24 nos traen la
historia
en tiempos normales en este cementerio
no se verían tumbas esperando ataúdes o
sepulturas sin identificar pero aquí
están esta es la realidad en la parte
nueva del cementerio militar de crans no
pil iba de mí pero desde que comenzó la
guerra en ucrania
varios días a la semana a micael lysenko
vicealcalde de ni pero recibe
información de las morgues donde se
acumulan los cuerpos de los soldados
muertos en la guerra pero algunos
cuerpos no son fáciles de identificar y
les tomamos el adn y cuando las familias
nos lo piden lo comparamos
para determinar de dónde es el soldado y
quiénes son sus allegados
dice que aún hoy no hay investigaciones
independientes que lo corroboren lysenko
dice que también hay cuerpos de soldados
rusos muertos en localidades como tones
jarquín y lugansk nos lleva hasta el
camión frigorífico donde los han
colocado y permite que los veamos pero
no lograremos no podemos tomar
estas informaciones no pueden ser
difundidas en base a las leyes
ucranianas y has visto que en las bolsas
con los nombres y apellidos no queremos
hacer daño a sus parientes y que se
enteren de su muerte a través de un
reportaje
en la guerra de ucrania ni la muerte
tiene tregua
entre tanto una serie de ataques
terroristas sacudió a la región
separatista moldava de transnistria el
primero se produjo con lanzagranadas
contra el edificio del ministerio de
seguridad del estado luego hubo dos
explosiones en la oficina de
radiotelevisión del pueblo de mayak y
posteriormente fue atacada una unidad
militar en parca ni la presidenta del
país maya sandú aseguró que los hechos
son responsabilidad de las fuerzas
internas de transnistria que buscan
desestabilizar el país
y en medio de la atención entre rusia y
la unión europea moscú decidió cortar a
partir del miércoles del suministro de
gas a polonia y bulgaria luego de que
ambas naciones se negaron a pagar en
rublos como exige el kremlin desde el
primero de abril para proteger su divisa
en medio de las sanciones
internacionales
el gobierno polaco ya dijo que el
combustible ruso puede reemplazarse por
flujos desde otros proveedores y que por
ahora no requiere liberar sus reservas
y hemos recibido amenazas de la
federación rusa de gazprom
están relacionados entre otras cosas con
el método de pago polonia se apega a los
arreglos y quizás rusia intente castigar
a polonia de esta manera
como es subrayado muchas veces polonia
se había preparado previamente para
diversificar el suministro de gas y
obtener gas en varias direcciones gas e
incluso antes de que se inaugure el
gasoducto del báltico
podremos proteger nuestra economía
proteger a los hogares y a los polacos
frente a una situación tan dramática
vamos a américa latina las autoridades
de méxico anunciaron que el país dejará
de tratar el hobby 19 como pandemia para
pasar a la etapa endémica de la
enfermedad de ahora en adelante dejará
de usarse el llamado semáforo epidémico
que indicaba el nivel de riesgo para
cada estado desde ciudad de méxico mario
carbón el corresponsal de france 24 nos
ampliaba más temprano la información
en méxico prácticamente se está
declarando el fin de la etapa epidémica
para dar paso a una fase endémica en
cuanto al cobit 19 así lo aseguró en
conferencia de prensa hugo lópez gatell
el responsable del combate al sars cop 2
el funcionario dijo que la organización
mundial de la salud analiza algunos
criterios que a reserva de formalizarse
nos indican cuando podemos hablar del
paso de la etapa epidémica a la fase
endémica y méxico dijo cumple con todos
estos criterios que son alta capacidad
de respuesta alta cobertura de
vacunación y baja incidencia de muertes
y de casos a este respecto el
funcionario señaló que en mexico la
ocupación de camas de hospitales es de
sólo el 2% lo que refiere una alta
capacidad de respuesta la cobertura de
vacunación en población adulta es del
90% y ya se ha abierto el registro para
menores de 12 años en adelante en cuanto
a las muertes el promedio diario es de 4
y no se llega a 300 en cuanto a casos
confirmados derivado de ello se
relajarán algunas medidas por ejemplo ya
no se publicará diaria el reporte con la
situación de kobe 19 en el país
desaparece el semáforo epidémico este
cas vertía el nivel de riesgo para cada
estado de la república y quizá el punto
más polémico lópez gatell dijo que si
bien en méxico nunca fue obligatorio a
nivel federal el uso de cubrebocas hoy
podemos decir que su uso el uso de la
mascarilla ya no es imprescindible este
último punto ha generado algunas
reacciones en contra de especialistas
incluso algunos gobernadores pues
advierten que no es momento aún de
desincentivar el uso del cubrebocas y en
venezuela la asamblea nacional de
mayoría oficialista eligió a los
magistrados que conformarán el tribunal
supremo de justicia durante los próximos
12 años la constitución no establece que
los juristas sólo pueden integrar la
corte durante un periodo no obstante en
esta ocasión hay varios repitentes la
oposición venezolana rechazó la
designación
daniela zambrano corresponsal de france
24 nos dio más detalles
una designación que de antemano haya
sido rechazada por organizaciones no
gubernamentales defensoras de derechos
humanos que lo consideran
inconstitucional la ong de acceso a la
justicia destaque incluso que de los 20
supuestos nuevos magistrados dos se
repiten en el cargo quien era presidente
del tsj michael moreno repite como
magistrado la ex presidenta del tsj
gladys gutiérrez vuelve al máximo
tribunal quien hasta ahora la rectora
del consejo nacional electoral tania d
amelio de antiguamente diputada por el
partido socialista unido de venezuela es
ahora uno de los magistrados designados
también calixto ortega ex diputado del
partido socialista unido de venezuela y
como inspectora del tribunal supremo de
justicia que dos designa gladys requena
quien hasta antes de su fragmentación
también era diputada del partido
socialista unido de venezuela cuando ha
ido a través de un comunicado instado a
la comunidad internacional a no
reconocer esta supuesta renovación del
poder judicial considera que es un
ejemplo más de la falta de democracia en
venezuela y que fue un proceso que sólo
busca proteger a corruptos y violadores
de derechos humanos en momentos en los
que organismos internacionales intentan
llevar a cabo un proceso judicial en
venezuela como es el caso de la corte
penal internacional que investiga si se
cometieron delitos de lesa humanidad en
el año 2016 durante las protestas
antigubernamentales
y finalizamos en brásil la escuela de
samba grande río es la campeona del
carnaval de río de janeiro 2022 se trata
de la escuela que llevó al sambódromo el
candomblé es decir el culto de las
orillas una de las religiones
afrobrasileñas los jurados eligieron a
la representación del municipio de duque
de caxías por tan solo tres décimas
sobre la escuela beija-flor el carnaval
de río 2022 se celebró por primera vez
fuera de época tras dos años cancelado
por la pandemia del cob y 19
con estas imágenes nos despedimos pero
volvemos en breve con más noticias aquí
en france 24
[Música]